so I want to have a look at this first
question together and we can interpret
what's going on so it says the lift in a
six story building started at the ground
floor so this is actually kind of
related to a travel graph but it's not
actually about distance
it's about floors so closely related but
not the same it went to the second floor
then the fifth then the third before
returning to ground which of the
following is it so have a look don't
just shout out the answer just yet look
at the different options that you've got
here what might be helpful is to think
about where does the lift go and can I
map that onto here so we've got starting
at ground do all of the lifts started
ground on these different informal
graphs here afford at restaurant do they
all start at ground they look like
they'll Snyder ground so I can ignore
that fact since they're all the same
then it goes to the second so you can
see here's the second floor here so
which other graphs can we now eliminate
now that we know we've got to get to the
second floor that's the first
destination yeah CMD they go to the what
is that that's the fifth floor and this
one is their third floor so we can
discount those okay then we have a look
up we're going to after the second floor
our next destination
yeah it doesn't go in order skips over
the third in the fourth goes to the
fifth so now you can probably tell me
which one it is right it's going to be B
and we can confirm this we actually
didn't need that last piece of
information okay so the key here is when
you're looking at these graph you need
to interpret them and look closely at
what they're asking and what they're
telling you about now if you have a look
over to the next one this one asks you
to create your own graph and we're going
to do this together let me zoom in a bit
bigger because my eyesight is terrible
so if you don't have one already get a
ruler up and we're going to create an
informal graph for this we'll do it on
the board together okay we've got a
triathlete and they have the following
training program for a marathon by the
way how many kilometers in a marathon 42
is anyone what's the longest distance
anyone's run before anyone is anyone
let's call it walk like actually gotten
to the end actually no no don't count
that because like hiking I've done like
40 corners that's that's training I've
got 14 flown is zero know what for
- in Kalama disease in Sydney that says
importantly no one done the city to surf
yep okay so we're going to do a lot more
than that
marathons are more than triple that
length we're gonna start at 5 a.m. okay
so do you remember I'm just gonna bring
it back our graph here it starts at what
home it starts at 8 a.m. right so we're
gonna have to start earlier than that
you can start up your graph at whatever
point in time makes sense so if we draw
kind of a vertical axis a vertical axis
is going to be a a distance right and
then we've got a horizontal axis for our
time now you might notice this is just
like the travel graphs we looked at
yesterday but we're constructing one
which we didn't really do yesterday we
were just um interpreting ones that
we've given to us already so starts at 5
so let's all mark in we've got a 5 a.m.
time slot right here and we're going to
end and I'm going straight to the end of
the day or the end of his day anyway
going to this final time because then I
know how much of this I need to use
there's no point kind of like putting
all the times I'm interested in in the
first half and they're leaving all the
rest of it okay so where should my thing
end 10 o'clock so is that the final time
so the whole thing's gonna be 5 hours
okay so mark Ian at 10 a.m. time slot
okay
all right now you've got to keep in mind
that there's actually three legs to this
and each one it gives you a different
distance and also a different amount of
time as well as these rest stops okay so
what's the furthest he's going to go he
goes 12 in one hit but then he kind of
keeps going have a look at the next one
he goes eight kilometers in the next one
yeah after that he comes home yeah so
this is like the first part so I'm going
to say the total distance the furthest
he ends up away from home is not 12
it's not a ditz it's twelve and eight
together which is
20 good and I'm doing that so I can mark
in a useful spot on my scale and so that
I don't like say all 12s up here and
then I'm like oh no where am I going to
go after that so I'm taking account all
the information in as I construct my
axes so we'll call that one 20 now
coming back to what you said before I
need a 12 marker right so I'm going to
go halfway as I don't have a ruler on me
that's gonna be 10 so I'll go a little
bit further than that to make it 12 now
I'm going to pause at this point this is
a bit of a start I don't let you see now
that you've got this same framework can
you fill in the amount of information
that you think would be helpful given
that you've got your x you might like to
put in a few more times by the way and
we've also got our distances sure all
the graph that you think you've you're
going to come up with use a ruler if you
can and then if you think you've gone on
to call me ever and I'll have a look
okay all right I've looked around I've
seen a lot of great graphs some of us is
struggling to get the interpretation
right so I'm going to show you how I've
done it okay now I helped you guys work
out a vertical scale and a horizontal
scale but you might notice I put on a
bunch of information since then that
some of you put on some of you haven't
so I want to sort of tell you why I've
done it I marked in my hours because I
just wanted to space it out but you'll
notice I didn't actually label every
single hour I didn't measure mark in 6
or 8 and other like sort of half
intervals I looked at the question and I
read through it to work out well which
are the actual times that matter to me
why did I mark in 7 o'clock as the first
time after 5 yeah very good
he goes for 2 hours actually think it's
a run to begin with he runs for the
first two hours continuously right so I
don't actually care about what happens
in between 6 o'clock that time doesn't
matter to me
7 o'clock is two hours later so I've got
this vertical line because you guys some
of you have great books but some of you
don't so this helps me make sure I put
this on the right spot how far does he
go two hours he goes 12 kilometers very
good so I'm gonna go over to where that
12 is I'm gonna measure across and I'm
gonna line that up with 7 o'clock okay
after is to our first run what's his
next step yeah he has a break so some of
us forgot to include the breaks or put
them at different spots so he doesn't go
anywhere because we said that that's a
horizontal section of the graph where he
stopped okay so I can fill these in
there I've got that join there which is
his stationary part and then this is
where we begin okay now you can see
because I've done all this work already
it's kind of easy a lot of her thoughts
been done for me because I just know to
go to the x first and then the distances
after his next section after what is it
an hour
where does he end up Tim can you tell me
where he ends up after this step he's
done his rest his first rest then what
happens he say again he yes he's got a
30 but where did he go where does he end
up that's the time but where will he be
yeah so he's going to go another 8 which
is why we might in the 20 right so this
is a win question and this is a where
question so it's really important we
distinguish between them so I'm going to
pop in that at 20 and then I can pretty
much I think most of you got the rest of
it from here he does his next rest and
then finally he come home so you could
draw a straight line all the way to 10
a.m. and that's roughly what your graph
should look like